Hello Well, good afternoon or good
evening depending on where you are
and my name is Fernando Benavides, for
those who don't know me, I am a veterinarian from
the University of Buenos Aires, but I have been
working here at the MD
Anderson Cancer Center in Texas for 15 years and I am the
director.  of a
Rat and Mouse genetics service, fundamentally mouse, and
well, the topic we are going to discuss today is
precisely related to the
genetic quality of mice and the importance
of the genetic background, let's say in
the different
models, fundamentally the
genetically modified ones. I apologize
that  The slides are in English
but I will translate what is necessary and
most of them are scientific works that
are obviously already in English that I
could not translate. If anyone is interested in
something, you can send me an email. Here
you have the email on the slide and well
After the presentation I am going to
answer the questions so I am going to
leave that for
last, just one slide that
I wanted to use in the form of an introduction
is so that we can all agree
that everything I am going to tell you today
has to be understood in  the context
of what in English are known as iners
strains but in Spanish they are
inbred strains or isogenic strains
depending on the country the name but they are
really genetically
identical individuals among themselves those that belong to
a line and and in addition to being genetically
identical they are homos  Sigot for all its
loci or genetic losi that is a
unique characteristic of these lines,
both rat and mouse or any other
inbred line because
basically, to put it
graphically, the paternal and maternal chromosome
are a photocopy, they are identical, therefore
all the alleles  All
the controls that I am going to comment on and
all the concepts have to be
understood in this context of
the  inbreeding of
mice What are the issues that
concern us Eh fundamentally I'm not going to
try to list them little by little
uh for many years when I started
all this about 20 years ago uh the only
concern we had was with
respect to quality  Genetics was,
uh, what was called
genetic monitoring, genetic quality control, was
to be sure that there was no
genetic contamination, which is something that
happens very frequently, as it says on the
slide, uh, genetic contamination, in
reality, it's easy, it's simply when
they accidentally cross each other.  mice from two
different lines and as a consequence
genetic contamination of that line
is quite common. Here I show you
some historical examples, some of them are
quite old. Here is one from 82, one
from the 90s, one that I published
in the late 90s.  also in
Argentina and one of the 2000 where there are
many more cases, they have not been reported
but where cases of
genetic contamination have been published, notice that this
first one on the left is an article
in the magazine Science where it
is obviously a serious problem because the
results  that come from
contaminated animals, no, they are not valid. I will
go over this topic quickly because
today the panorama has changed a lot
and first of all, the big sellers of
inbred strains are the ones in
charge of doing the
genetic controls. So normally a
vivarium  or an animal facility does not usually
carry out this type of controls as it was
done in another time, perhaps in
Latin America a little more so that they have
less
possibility of doing these controls
but Generally in the United States or
Europe they are not usually done
and the other change  What was
historical is that most of the
vivariums and animal farms now eh They do not
have inbred animals
practically very few have 90 percent
or sometimes more genetically
modified animals transgenic knockouts
knockin that are generally in
mixed backgrounds It is the main topic of my
talk today  Therefore this this
old genetic control genetic monitoring
is no longer so common and is not so much of a
concern for us. I
also put a single
slide so that you have an idea of ​​the
historical context How these controls
that could be called purity were carried out.  Also,
in which we simply verified that
the strain was pure, the b c or the c57 or the
c3h is pure. Historically,
markers of coat color were used, other markers of
morphology, which for example were measured
in the animal's jaw,
biochemical markers, certain enzymes, certain
proteins, sometimes  immunological and
finally the last 15 or 20 years
DNA markers that are the same ones that we are
going to comment on that I am going to comment on
with respect to the control of the
genetic background and the other topics that I am going to
present
Today there is a topic that is given very
little attention  attention and that is why I put it in the
presentation and that There is very little
knowledge on the part of the
researchers, the students and the
veterinary technicians that it is the
existence of subs, which in English
is a
subst, that is, you know that originally  They were
the same but they were separated and they have
diverged over time and therefore they
have genetic differences that,
although they are minimal because they are still
99% identical depending on the strain.
But well, there is a 5%
difference that could be  As I put in
the slide, very very drastic, that is, and that is
what I want to try to convince you now
of how important it is to pay attention
to the issue of supas and not
easily believe that all c57 B are the
same or that all c3h are  the same
because it is not the
case
as I am going to quickly present four cases
here of how the
sub strains are generated fundamentally. It is
a genetic difference that has to
arise or from a uh of a
genetic polymorphism that already existed in the Colony is
the  case when one does not complete the
endocrine process and certain
genetic differences remain and one separates the
animals or else the other case that is perhaps
more common is the accumulation of
spontaneous mutations, let's say all the
time
the genomes are mutating and well And that is what
happens.  It accumulates and something
called
genetic drift is formed and that causes the
colonies to slowly
separate and differentiate
genetically. Some cases of
genetic contamination have
also contributed to the formation of their sea, but
that is just another case.  more particular,
rarer and on a practical level, the last point
of the slide is that when you separate two
colonies of the same origin, you separate them,
we consider today that they are separated
by more than 20 generations and
the generations are counted in both institutes, I
give you  my mice to a person to a
researcher and I count well the 10
generations in my institute plus the 10
of the other person add up to 20 from
that number one supposes that there is enough
amount of genetic changes to
call the subs and we can change it no
change the name but add, as
we are going to see now, after the name, the
bar and a new laboratory code
indicating that it is a different cefa from the
original. Here are some examples, my
presentation, as you will see, is full
of examples and I do not intend for you to remember
any details.  of genetics or
molecular of none are examples that
I use to convince you that this is
important This is an example of let's say
that it is classic in some way I know it
c3h I'm going to mark it here It has two
classic uploads, one of which is the one that comes from
Jackson  That's why the J, which is what is
called the laboratory code, and the n, which
comes from n, the laboratory code, as you
can see, the rest of the
nomenclature of the strain is the same
because c3h is the bar and H is the
researcher called Heston who
developed the strain these strains have been
separated for many years and therefore
now it is considered that they are sub
you know well it was known for many years that they
had a different behavior in
immunological studies fundamentally
when they were evaluated against  the al
to the LPS product of bacteria and well and that
is what is published in this article
that I am showing you from the
Science magazine of the 90s where they
show that Jackson's J strain has
an amino acid, it is a polymorphism, not the
protein in this  Gene tlr4 has a
different amino acid in the J subsa that
the n does not have And that makes the
difference that was known for so many
years in this immunological behavior
but the message again is the same I
cannot mix or I cannot use
as a control  For example,
knockout mice that have been in this one that
are in a background c3h and compare them with
another background that is n instead of J all
the results will be eh They will not
serve another example, you will see that I continue
with many examples balc has  These are several
subsp that I show you here, the
classic one from Jackson, which is the B CJ, was
separated around 80 years ago with
another one that was called by because the
researcher's name is Bailey Biley and
as you can see in this publication, the two
supas have different behavior  and
they have important genetic differences
in gene copies, etc. And once again I
cannot use them as a control. I have to
be very clear about what I am
asking. Ask the researcher what
he is asking because the
message is always the same.
Val is not the same as another
Val that we must take into account if
we want and
within subsa there is none more
important than this one due to the fact that
the c57 bl6 is the most used mouse cpa
in the world today is the
bottom line  genetic of the vast majority of the
inbred strains that are used
from the transgenics and knockouts and
it also has two subs and there are
many more but the best known are the
Jackson strain again with the j and the ni
which has the n Here
Just in case you want to read it, I show you a
couple of reviews where they talk about the issue
of problems and sometimes
surrenders because for those who work
in genetics sometimes the differences, on the
contrary, are good because they allow us
to find genes that have to do with
certain phenotypes.  but for
general use that is not the case and that is what I wanted to
focus on a little bit. Now on the
difference between what is known as
b6 J to put it in a more
abbreviated form b6 J or b6n are both the two
most used subs and that as  I mean, the
majority is unaware that this
difference exists and where
the problems can begin if one goes to buy these
little mice from a site, for example, here I
put the Jackson site. The
two uploads obviously have a different catalog.
Because they are essentially two
different products, no.  I can go
buy it without seeing if I want the J or
I want the n here the same thing here the n
simply has a J after the n
because it is maintained in Jackson but it
is the subsea n and it has a
different sales catalog number and it has a
lot  of characteristics, you will not be
able to read it but I am going to explain the
most important of them and how it can
be fundamental in some cases, not in
all, but in some cases
it was discovered in 2010 in this
work, that is, relatively
recently the  subp J, the one that comes from
Jackson has a lesion that
practically eliminates a gene
completely, which is the nnt Gene that you see
in this work, therefore the c57 bl6
J are natural knockouts because this
was natural, they are natural for this Gene.
This was not known  a few years ago but the
change is not and then look at
this work as it shows differences in
weight gain between above they go to
ha the n and below the J this is just an
example let's say this Gene has to do
with mitochondrial functions and with others
things too but again my point is
the same as I can never use
control of a knockout that is in a
background n an animal that is in the background J
or use mixed animals
mixed animals a drama when a ti mix
of j and n because simply  one year
he bought j and another year it is cheaper and he
buys n and the researcher out there doesn't even
know it so this is another example another
example about the same problem in this
case it is a group that worked on this
knockout of the bcl2 L2 Gene But they
realized that  Depending on whether they had this
noc in one background or the other, the
survival was completely different
when it was in the background n
with the normal Gene nnt w, the survival
was
25% when the same knockout bcl2 L2
was in the other background J with the  of
nnt injury the survival dropped
a lot to 6% And again the same thing
I cannot compare data in a knockout with
these two backgrounds mixed the
results will never be valid and
in general this is ignored that is the
problem This is the example  clearer
about the issue of n versus J for
b6, this group works with another knockout,
G is jn k2 and they actually did
the study of comparing this knockout with
two different types of wtp, one in J and the other
in N and notice that it is  The
difference is dramatic, you will see that when you
compare it with the J, the knockout seems to
have, that is, the Gene actually
seems to have a protective effect on the
liver. This is a liver study. The
details do not matter when
the comparison is made with the eh.  The subsa n
the effect is totally opposite to
what they put in this figure, that is, a
totally opposite effect depending on the W
type that one uses, you can conclude something
directly opposite. That is, it is
impossible to clearer than this to show you how
important it is to know if  I am
using the J or the N Or if I have one that
is mixed between the
two, finally, whoever is interested
has
this paper, this publication that is
very recent from last year 2013, which is
the most extensive description there is about
the differences between the j and  The n have
all the sequences analyzed, both
subs have completely sequenced
the genome. And in this work, anyone who
wants to read it has all the details.
What are the molecular markers
that differentiate them? There are, for example, about
200 snips that are single nucle
polymorphism. These changes of a  single
nucleotide between these two strains and Well,
there are a lot of genes among those that
I mentioned that affect, let's say, they explain the
difference between these rises. In the same
work they show another example in this
case of
behavior, the time it takes for the
animal to fall from those wheels  what they call
rot r are T pamiento o de also stop
exercise and look at the difference
between the j and the n again in the
latency time before falling is quite
large and a paper that just came out
is practically December of
last year and nothing  less than in Science where
they describe a gene that is already described in
the paper that I showed you before but here
let's say they analyze more why the
difference in the response in this case
cocaine between strain n and j and something
interesting to see in this work here
They have the Gene that has the polymorphism
is cy
fp2 but look how interesting they
discovered at what exact moment this
gives the idea of ​​what I told them about
the colonies that separate in time
and diverge, notice that in the
60's Apparently  when one of
these colonies separates and gives rise to all the
colonies that are in green here, which are
those of the subsa n that still sells
taconic and v r for example and K Jackson
are also all those that carry
this mutation and that of course there are  To take this
into account if you are working
on something related to the subject, I am not saying that it
is always essential 100% of the time.
It is very likely that other types of
studies will not affect me having N or having J,
but in many studies it is more than
fundamental, it is
essential.  I'm going to let it go by itself
too quickly to just mention it,
but unfortunately
no one follows the nomenclature. And that's a
problem because I'm saying that
you have to know if it's J or if it's n, but
if the researcher, the working group
doesn't know.  It says in the article that
publishes how we are going to know,
the nomenclature is followed very little. Unfortunately,
and whoever is interested, that is
all on the internet, all the guides
on what to follow are on the
internet, here comes the site.  They keep
the Genom Informatics mouse in the mgi and they
have a site dedicated to that and eh. There is
a review that I put here if you are
interested, also from the year 2003 where
it plays a little with the terms. But
well, it deals with the problem and the importance
of the  follow a good
nomenclature, the good news
is that many magazines are beginning to
require, let's say, ask that
the nomenclature be followed. When you
send a paper, they return it to you
saying that it has to follow the
official standard nomenclature. This is the
list of magazines.  We hope that it continues to
grow because that would be essential
for the works to
really publish What is the subsa that
they used in the other important topic
today and that is the main title of my
presentation It is with respect to the
genetic background all the topics are
related of course Not because
The genetic quality of the seed, the sub
seed, are all basically the same and
everything has to do with the genetic background
of the model. In the last 10 or 15 years,
a lot of attention began to be paid to
this and now it is well confirmed that
The phenotype of a knockout or a
transgenic or a mutant
changes, it may not always change
enormously in two different genetic backgrounds,
so what we publish is
essential that it be described in a
defined genetic background and not in a
mixed background, which is unfortunately the
most common case in the vast majority of
knockouts due to a technical problem that
I will not explain now but that in the
way in which they are developed using
embryonic cells - most of them were
at least until recently from a cpa
129 a group  a family of cpas and
researchers do not like 129, they
cross it with b6, so a large
majority of the nocal are mixtures with 129
and b6 and well, and it also happens with
transgenics that are sometimes injected
into embryos of hybrids that have more
of a genetic background, etc. I'm going to
make a small
sample book. If you want, of
cases where examples where it has been very
important in rat and mouse models,
fundamentally mouse, the
background the genetic background to once
again convince them and they take the
main idea of ​​my presentation It's not that and
take the word elsewhere how
important this is and try to
educate those who work with you and
the researchers themselves. The
researchers are excellent in their area
but sometimes they don't pay attention  To
this topic, then with respect to
examples, there is only one very very very
old one, it is almost one of the practically
the first one is from the 70's but
already at that time if you see the
obese and diabetes mutations it was not known what
the genes were, that is  It was only discovered in
the 90s,
but it was seen at that time that
these two mutations ended up
being related because one is
leptin and the other is the
leptin receptor. It ended up being that in a
genetic background that they have here, which is
the  What we mentioned is 57 bl 6j,
obesity and diabetes are temporary.
For example, this may have to do
with the mutation that was recently discovered
and in another strain that is very
related, as you will see from the name,
but it is not the same and  fact This is
an example of a strain that we call a
subsa at one time It was called subsa
because it was thought that it was a
subsa but now it was considered a
new strain Because there is
genetic contamination involved So they changed
the name the issue is that  In that background, in
that second genetic background, the same
mutation in the same mutation, no one
has touched it, they are two natural spontaneous mutations,
the phenotype changes
drastically, obesity and diabetes
become very evident.
Unlike the other genetic background,
one of the first examples.  from the 90s
about in this case another
spontaneous mutation that was called
min now it is known that the affected Gene
ap but in this work again when
this mutation was in background b6 as
you can see here the left pure background
b6 the number of intestinal tumors  It was,
for example,
but in the background akr mixed with
b6, as you will see here on the right,
the number of tumors changed and the number
of tumors dropped dramatically. If I am analyzing a
drug that I believe prevents the
formation of intestinal tumors and
I have a background of mixed animals
between hr and b6 my my my information is going to
be totally wrong because I am going to
have the influence of both genomes
Changing the number of tumors in the
animals and it is not going to be the drug
Ultimately the system is going to be
totally dirty, not another example
This is one of the first the first
perhaps in which a knockout the other
the others in the spontaneous mutations
is a knockout developed let's say
through directed mutagenesis And look
how important it was that
two groups published it in Science as they say in
English  back to Back two works
published in the same journal side
by side where they demonstrated that the
mouse knockout for the ef the
gf receptor dramatically changed survival
are in the part that I marked there
in table one according to the background was cf1
which is actually an exo fund bred
outb or 129 or cd1, the animals died, for
example, the knockouts in cf fund, they
all died, none of them were born. The same in
fund 129 but in the cd1 fund, for
example, there was a survival rate of 16,
a dramatic change in  the
phenotype even though it is the same
knockout the same knockout allele But
simply the genetic background obviously
this is known today that it has to do
with genes that modify other
genes they are not called modifying genes or
epistatic effects in which there are
genes  that influence
others and that is what changes the phenotype I
am going to move a little faster because the
rest are just examples This is another
historical example from the 90s another noout
This is a this case is a tumor suppressor gene
p53 and this group  The same thing
showed that both the
heteros and the
homozygous if they were in the b6 background
mixed with 129 had a different life
than they will be pure 129 The same for the
knockout eh homos Sigot knockout and the
same for the type of tumor that is more
dramatic if you look  there in the background b6
129 the type of tumor the percentage of
lymphoma for example very different than the
background is pure 129 the percentages
of lymphoma decrease other types of tumor appear
How can I work with a model for
example on a knockout as important
as this  in which the background of the
mice is mixed 129 with b6 and in
which one mouse noout is different from the
other one next to it because my entire group of
noout can be noout everything but mouse
one has a percentage of 129 times
different from mouse two  to TR and to cu That is the
serious
problem I continue with the examples and some
comments more quickly in the late 90s
in the 90s the group that first
came out to defend the issue to say this is
very important were those who work
in neurology and released this series  of
recommendations that is still
available where they ask that the
models be
totally different backcross B
in this case it is the same noout It is not
another noc they have simply passed it to
balc with
backcross for example gives a breast tumor that is why
this work was published
another example  Deeper into
the 2000s, this is a knockout of the
dandruff 3 gene and once again, if it is at background
129, the survival of the homozygote is
minimal, it is 3%, for example, but if it is at
background b6, the
survival rate is an order of magnitude greater. And if
I work with animals  mixed, the
results are really practically
invalid, notice here that in the background in
the background
129 the mouse develops deformities in
the head in the brain but never
develops them in the background b6
eh more examples other gene suppose tumor
in this case Pit the same  It was published in
2006 that according to the genetic background,
the same knockout in this case is
heterozygous because the homozygote dies.
Look at it, for example, here the
percentage of the incidence of lymphomas,
the change it has depending on the background is
mixed 129 with 7 with balc  For example,
that is a difference, but it is huge, huge.
In passing, I take the opportunity to show you how they do not
follow the standard nomenclature because
none of these names in this work
are good, it is very bad, the
incorrect nomenclature has been presented incomplete c57 It does
not mean anything c57 could be 15 or
20  different cpas of which not
even c57 bl6 because there is bl10 there are
others is an example that also serves me
for that to see how badly the
nomenclature is followed And how are other
researchers going to know what they know was
used here if not if not
nomenclature a single example in rat
But of course there are many more but
fewer have been published This is a
spontaneous mutation of the rat And once again the
same thing if it is in a background eh
f344 which is a background of an
inbred strain of rat the  survival is what
you see here on the green line and if
instead it is in a background it
is another another inbred strain of
rat the change the survival is enormous
they survive much less just by changing the
genetic background the phenotype changes And that
is my
main message  If you want to read a couple of
reviews or guides like there are here in
Jackson, you can download for
free the guide that I put
up here about a kind of manual on
the importance of the genetic background and
then there is a review that is a little
old but  It's very good. Maybe
most of the topics are here,
maybe the examples are old but the
topic is good and if you're interested in
a little more genetics, eh, this is a
much more recent review from last year
where it analyzes in a context.  now
more genetic and also playing a
little bit of a word game, not because it says
who needs a
background study, let's say no background check
with the police but in reality it
means that no. That is, the genetic background of the
know and different
genetic studies and in  This review explains a
little more why not all the
W type mice that one uses are
the same, not because they are W
type makes them the same because if they have
a genetic background from a different strain
there are modifying genes, as you see there are
alleles that are going to have
specific effects or epistatic effects that are
called between genes, that is, those who are
a little more interested in the topic Endo
this
review within the same
topic of the genetic background and the Sub
know it is simply a
name problem when  The Gene that is different or
that is having an effect is
actually identified in some
works, it is considered or called
as
passenger genes or I would not know how to
translate it
passation genes that are there but we do
not really want them are there
because they are in the  genetic background but they
can influence us in our
research and well now some
examples of that I wanted to show you. This
is an example in the strain 129 S6 and as you
can see here in the figure of the
paper there is the line 129 S6 has a
large  lesion within the Gene,
therefore it is a knockout, a natural knockout
for the Gene that is called dis One and that
c57 b6 does not have it but
other strains do have it, we must also be
careful with that, not other strains derived
from mice.  swis have that injury
So it is always important I cannot
answer yes but if I am
studying memory and
learning it is essential as you see
in these works because this influences
memory it will influence all the
learning memory tests and if I have mixed
b6 mice with 129 c6 obviously the results
are all affected another gene of this
type passenger
eh it is also not relatively
recent work from a few years ago eh
fbb has fewer increases but it has some
And in this case it was discovered that in the
know that it has let's say or  who maintains
that he sells taconi for that reason The Tac which is
the taconi laboratory code was
discovered only in this cpa and not in others
also
a mutation that produces a
truncated protein in a gene called
skin One is not interested in the detail at this time
But what makes it so that only the
vi mice that come from Taconic
have, as I am going to show you, now
a part of the protein practically disappears,
that part that is there in
the ones from Taconic is not there, therefore
it is also a kind of knockout.
natural natural mutant for this Gene And
if one is a gene that has a lot to do
with immunology and especially
immunology in the skin then yes I
have and it has happened in our institute
because they work a lot on skin cancer
I have a  transgenic in a
viv
fbb background and everyone panicked
Because we started sequencing and analyzing
people didn't even remember if it was a
heel or not which is natural I would
n't remember either but we had to
start going through the history of all
the colonies and see if they were vivid or
not if they were from taconic or were from
somewhere else and we developed a PCR to
genotype this particular gene to see
if they were indeed from one to the other
because the studies in skin cancer
could be totally  and the results
totally influenced by this by
this
mutation more examples another example in
129 all 129 have a deletion in
caspase 4 that b6 does not have if I
am a researcher studying caspases
or studying apoptosis this is
essential to know and and most of me  It is known
that no does not
know another very recent another very
recent example is the year 2012 it is a year and a
half it was only discovered that the
subsa n of b6 c57 bl6 n of the and all
the embryonic lines of
embryonic cells and that are used  to
develop, for example, in the
International consortium called comp,
all of them have one in
homozygous form, as shown in the slide, one
from a lesion in a gene. It's good that it is
called crb1 but it produces a
retinal development problem, which is why it
is  called rd8 or rd8 because
it is generation e retinal and the problem
is that this rat does not have the same
vision as a c57 b j they have
vision problems and therefore if I put them in
a behavioral study where
vision has to see the results a
More and more they will be changed if I
have J mixed with n no no it is not something
that is convenient eh other reviews in case you are
interested
eh what has to do a little with all
this that I am saying about the genes of
the mutations that accumulate in  the
different strains because naturally
these mutations exist and since we
maintain them to the
inbred lines by doing endocris,
we favor some to be fixed and
not others but we favor to be fixed and to
maintain those mutations unless
they are deleterious for health and it was given
all these mutations Now when they do not
affect health and there is no
very obvious phenotype, it is called quiet
mutation with
quiet silent mutations That are dispersed in all
inbred strains and that
are just beginning to come to light now
because they are beginning to  sequence
many strains, there are already
around 20 inbred strains
completely sequenced and that is why this is
This is a review that deals with the topic and it was
up to us here in my
laboratory to find one of these
mutations we published last year of the
work there are several  strains related to
the family of swis and dba mice that
have a mutation in this gene that does not
have any phenotype But it may
eventually be important in some
immunological studies fundamentally
good to not throw so much bad vibes at it
what could be some
solutions to the issue from the point of view  From the point of
view of the creation of
genetically modified mice or rats, there are
some recommendations and one of them
is to try from the beginning to prevent
the genetic background from being mixed, which
is what has been happening until now
with the
e 129 lines that were later mixed with the
background b6 when one formed the chimera or
or crossed the knockout if not already inject
eh For example well in this case
I am now putting the transgenic or
the fingerless nucleases or the Talent
or the now fashionable crisp cas n
in a background  pure, for example in a
zygote from a consanguineous line like
fbb, I avoid the
mixing of funds from the beginning, the same if I work
when I create the chimeras or my
founders in
the classic way of doing knockout And
noin if I cross my kimera through the background  which
is a background equal to the
embryonic cell that I used, I also avoid
that mixture and now there is a great
advantage that there was not before is that there are
many cell lines of these
embryonic cells that are used to make
knockout and noing that are7 b6 so
Therefore, it would be ideal for me to do the
inv vitro work in one of those cells
and then inject into a blastocyst from the
same line and therefore minoc
becomes pure from that genetic background. And no and not
mixed, these are three great
recommendations that  Before
generating the model, can I give you what
recommendation I can give you after
the model already exists and you no longer
want it, you cannot go back. Well,
one of them is to do a control, let's say
a background characterization to at
least know.  What do I have so that the
researcher at least knows what he
has and decides what to do? And even better
is to end up developing what he calls
a congenital line in which I move
my mutant or my transgene or my knockout
or my noin to  a new fund through
backcrossing
fundamentally Sorry for
the background characterization and to
develop lees with genetics we need
tools and the tools I
present to you Now I need
genetic markers that allow me to differentiate
when something is b c or c3h or c57 or b6n o6
J yes  I don't, I don't have that tool,
I can't do anything good. The tools
are the genetic markers. This is
just a slide. I don't have time to
explain it today, but fundamentally, the
last 15 years have been using
microsatellites and in the last 8 years, let's
say that's how things are now.  using
the nips more but both are valid, we both
still use them in our service today and here I show you
some examples of the classic way
of viewing them in a gel or viewing them with
fluorescence with primers that show
fluorescence or another type of study.
for snips with fluorescence here on the
right but fundamentally they are
markers that
allow me to determine if a
DNA segment in a chromosome belongs to one strain
or another that is fundamentally why
we use them because they are very
polymorphic and they are very changeable between
cpas these  markers allow us to do
that
eh in the case of a
background characterization for example to give a
classic example we use around 100
microsatellites this queir microsatellite
also simple sequence l polymorph is
the same as microsatellite or a little
more than snip 120 140 according to the  lines that we
are
analyzing distributed on all the
chromosomes that is why it is called G scan in
English I do a kind of scan of
all the marker chromosomes And
somehow I get an idea of ​​what
the genetic background of that model of that
stem of that noout is.  or of that mutant And
in that way we can estimate a
percentage of alleles of the background that
is involved and this is a
concrete example of our service from a
researcher from our department who
sent us four lines here I
only show some chromosomes because they do not
fit all of them.  the first soma n
as soma 4 in the particular case of
this example are all microsatellites and
what Tena Here are the four lines
not a knockout of k53 another
different knockout etcetera four
different knockouts that the researcher was
convinced were in the background
fbb the  reality showed something Quite
different, only one of the lines was
very close to reality, almost 100% 96
but the others were at levels of 80 and
even
7% or less, no less, no, but
70 that is what we do with a
background characterization and  That's why you
see all the colors that you see there because of
the different components that that
line had. There are two animals per line that are
analyzed. In this case, they can be analyzed
more, but sometimes two animals are enough,
as in this case, to determine that the
line is not  pure is something that is seen very
quickly and with relatively few
markers it decided to follow the route
of developing congenital lines and
today all these four lines
are in an fbb background that is
practically
99% thanks to what I am going to explain
now that  It is the speak
genic technique, before I refresh your memory or
for those who do not know how
a congenital line develops,
fundamentally I am
moving an allele of my interest, which is
the ro point that I mark here in this
white mouse, which is the knockout.  locus
knockout noing or trangen or mutant and I
want to go from a Val c background for
example to a c57 background which is from the
right recipient background donor background
this is simply done by crossing
mice it is not a
genetic engineering problem I cross and once
I get an f1 hybrid animal, I
make sure that I still have the trangen, the
genotypes and each of these
crosses is called a backcross because in
reality I am crossing towards the
background strain. Not necessarily the same
individual but an individual from the
pure strain in this case c57  As I
move, the nomenclature
of the letter n n2 n3 n4 is used And that way,
as you can see, The mouse is getting blacker and
blacker because it is getting blacker and blacker. 57 and When
generation 10 arrives, it is what is
considered in English.  As they say full
congenic,
the line is practically finished and more than
99% of the receiving fund has been considered. Now to do
this it
takes, it could take 3 years or four, it
depends because let's say the methodology in
this example that I show you the same ones
but  To make it more didactic, I
show you four random chromosomes in two
different colors so that you can differentiate
what a strain is, the giver and the
recipient with two different colors. We
are moving this trangen from the
Violet background so that it is understood, to the
green background, they are two different strains. I obtain  my
f1 a chromosome completely of one
color another completely of the other I
always take care to maintain my trangen
if not it doesn't make any sense and here
comes the first backcross and here comes
the problem or the
interesting thing the the backcross that
generation n2 the the the animals  f1 in
these animals obviously the
meiotic recommendation is formed and the chromosomes
recombine of course they do. Also
in the other but in the other we do not see it
because it is all from the same genetic background
green with green we see green but the
recombination that comes from this side  of
f1 eh we see how the chromosomes
start to have like a work of like
a sieve or a let's say a tapestry
Sorry where there are green and
violet colors Well that is what is
called n2 what is happening  Each
mouse n2 is different from the one
next to it, that has to do with what I
also told you before that when
I use an experiment, a group of noout
and a group of W types but that between
them are a greater mix. Something similar to this
slide, a mouse is  different from the one next to it, they
are not all the same, that is, Violet is
green and the proportion of Violet in
green in this one is different. The
proportion of donor fund and
giver fund is different in each of these
mice of each generation n2 or n3,
so  It occurred to a person,
well, what if we can choose that
mouse that has more of the background to which I
want to go to the receiving background, in this case
the green one. How can we choose
that mouse and well, as you can
imagine, using genetic markers that
already exist.  I told you that I can tell which mouse
of these has more of the receiving background or
the green background on this slide and that is
what I Marco here I choose through
this study that mouse that is in the
circle which is the one that has more of the
background  genetic of my interest that is
called Market assisted Back Crossing or
speaken and by doing
this I manage to uh let's say speed up the
process that's why the name from 4 years to
2 years from 3 years to a year and a half we have
even done here some
we do continuously  of this in the
institute and in some cases
even just a year because it depends
a little on luck and the number of
mice that one can analyze in each
generation This is what happens
simply the mathematical explanation Not
me the distribution of the quantity  The
genetic background of one strain or the other
is a standard distribution,
but in this case I am choosing,
when using the genetic markers,
those individuals, let's say extreme, in
this case that have, let's say, less
amount of background from the giver or let's say from
the cpa.  giver and therefore more of the
receiver in each generation I choose that
extreme animal and by doing that I accelerate the
process the very brilliant idea and it was
published in the year 97 there you have the
original work
of which they gave the name spe genix and
this is one  of the services that we are asked for the most
in our here in our Core,
as we say because obviously. The
researchers save time and
a lot of money,
their trains from one fund to another
by doing this method and not doing the
classic cross, there is only one problem that remains
and  With this we are going to finish and I leave
the last minutes for questions is
that beyond all the backcrosses that
we do and the amount of retouching that
we do around the locus that is called
differential locus, the
TR will always be obviously surrounded, it
will be crossed  by a
chromosomal segment of the original strain that gave
this allele because due to a
genetic linkage problem it
cannot be separated even after 20
generations, as you can see
here, the area that flanks
the gene of interest to the knockout, for
example, is enormous.  because here it is in
centimorgans but if we convert this to
megabases this is like six or if
megabases that those there are hundreds of
genes in a quantity in a
chromosome size like that But well it is the
only problem that you cannot one  take
out if not one would have to develop
the nocado again in a pure background.
Beyond here you cannot go and this is
what some called the problem of
genes franque anes and well if you are not
very unlucky like these people who
publish  Here they were working on
a knockout that just had a gene
modifying that Gene that they were
working on, close to the place
where the knockout was, so
to put it simply, they went crazy
with this system until they discovered
that the problem was  a frank gene
But well that is a rare case
normally having 99 or more 99%
pure background the model is considered
adequate And well for the last 5
minutes I will leave the conclusions and
we will answer the questions
eh the researcher the student or those
in charge  of the vivariums obviously have to
know which strains they have to
recommend which is the
most suitable and fundamentally which
subsa is most suitable if the researcher
is going to study diabetes, clarify that it
is not the same as weight gain
etcetera etcetera.
Another is to use the nomenclature both in
the vivariums on the cards and in the
animal protocols and in the works, you
have to use nomenclature c57 alone does not
mean anything b6 can be used
once one has clarified what the cpa is
Yes but normally somewhere in the
The full name must be on the work or poster or presentation.
Paying attention to the issue of the
genetic background is essential. It cannot be
ignored today with all the publications
out there, of which I showed you only a
few.  and well, and once one
has the model and if one has the
possibility of doing a
background characterization, at least one knows what one
has or a genetic control in the
case of
consanguineous cpas. And if it is possible
to develop then congenital lines
either  The classic form or the
accelerated form with genetic markers
are both valid, one is simply
faster but it is more expensive, the one to cross
is only obviously much
cheaper and all this carries something
important that we must not forget that
all this obviously carries  to the issue of
refinement and reduction in the number
of animals Because if I have a
pure background I will use fewer controls and I
will be disregarding many fewer
animals and it is considered part of this
refinement not of the use of
animals and good with the  last 5
minutes I'm going to start answering
questions I see that there are a few
here
okay Well there are some Greetings and
congratulations thank you I'm going to a
question that says why they always use
hybrids
for transgenics and and and
noout just because of the hybrid vigor is one
of  the questions Well it is a good
topic not to be transgenic Enoch but I know
that there are many who like to inject
hybrids for example of b6 and c3h or deba
and b6 obviously they have hybrid vigor
they are stronger they resist the
injection more but that is the  The problem
from the beginning is that the
transgenic line is in a background that
has two backgrounds. When I cross them, they
become f2 and when they are later crossed,
it is f3. F4 is a mixture in which no
mouse is the same as the other. I
personally advise against it.  inject
f1 hybrids for noout, they are not
used, they are used only for
transgenics But well, now you could
use Talent and without
finger and crisp again, I would recommend
not injecting
those gin editing mechanisms in a
hybrid, at least my  recommendation
but it is true that hybrids are
stronger hybrid embryos are stronger
Ah there is a person who has a problem
telling me that I have neither audio nor
video But well I can't
solve that anymore Where can I see the genotype
of the mouse lines  most used or
common
Ah It's difficult well the Jackson the mgi
is Mouse genome informatic is the
most complete place where one can find
all the lines information on all
the inbred lines and also on
knockout and transgenic I would go there
now
eh to answer the question  which are
the most used or common at a
statistical level I don't know
Oh well there are other thanks another
question In how many generations can I
lose the genetic information of a
line and that had to be seen because it
depends a lot on whether we are talking
about a congenital from an out of  an inbr
of a let's say consanguineous or a non-
consanguineous one and apart from that I don't understand what it
means to lose the
information, excuse me but the question
is not clear, they
ask me. Also, if there is any, there
is no tool
to let's
see, there is none that allows us to reduce
In those two years that
Gen's technique has been in place, there are some Well one of them is
obviously that of using
genetic markers But there are people who
called it High Speed ​​with something like that at
work, they are Japanese people who, instead of
waiting for the natural time of  maturation
of a male what Us grab a male
only in the work mach 17 days that
are not yet mature they sacrifice them and
remove the spermatogonia and
obviously do ixi and other other types of
assisted fertilization mixing let's say
the Mark assisted Back Crossing with
reproduction of this  assisted type S you
can even speed things up more but
well it is complicated no no they are not
easy techniques and I think that with
that I answered everything and I am
exactly with one minute of time
Ah I am already there so
well I greet you thank you for
having connected  and if you have
any questions you can send me the email
where I told you F benavid to the d @m
Anderson org
thank you
i